and he's played King B6 the king is
marching to try and take the pawn on B7
a critical moment if C2 you can't play
King C7 because Rook B1 black would win
but after C two Roxy Rook C1 and if
Bishop D3 I think he can give up The
Rook so something like this move and
he's played it he has to go Rook C3 he
has to stop the king coming to C7 you
need to make sure that you don't allow
that King on C7 Bishop D3 played and I
think King C7 is possible now maybe just
take on take on B7 give up The Rook for
the C2 Pawn your pawns are so strong
aren't they
um so for example Bishop takes B7 Rook
B1 and then I don't take the Rook I take
your pawn bishop takes and these two
pawns are they stronger than a rook I
think they probably are I mean two pawns
so close to queening but look at the
time Fabiano can he work this out with
now eight seconds left he's looking at
his score
he's gonna sacrifice The Rook wow it's
happening The Rook is off the board
and we're gonna see this ending two
pawns versus The Rook get the bishop out
the way and just try the queen I think
this is the way to play right
um Russia with Asics you can't rush with
A6 because B6 was hanging with the check
so he does move the bishop the B Pawn is
coming
and I think you could just push it just
push the a pawn what Prague is trying to
do Prague is going to try and take this
Pawn then give his Rook up for that pawn
and use his King to try and get a draw
this way there's still some chances so
F4 look at the evaluation bar the
evaluation bar is completely dropped
after that move prag coming in with the
King
what's happening now
it's what you said he will sacrifice The
Rook for the a pawn but the F Pawn just
makes it closer for black skin to get to
it and now rookie to Rook has Fabi just
has this just slipped out of fabby's
hand in one move A6 on the board you can
just take the F4 pawn put the Rook on A2
next what black the reason black is
drawing the black king So near White's
remaining pawns the white king is so far
away from the action so black can now
just start munching these pawns off and
it is a drawn that was just one move in
it it wasn't actually as easy as I
thought I thought Fabiano was winning
quite simply but in actual fact Tanya
the win wasn't easy there it wasn't
straightforward at all it's a draw
coming up what a game though Tanya I
mean fabby's gonna be kicking himself
there
and Simon there we have it just Kings
and Bishops on the board handshakes